as things heat up between pete davidson
and kim kardashian a source tells e.t
what kanye west really thinks about his
estranged wife's new romance
et source explains that the 41 year old
skims founder and the 28 year old
saturday night live star had a great
time on their recent vacay to the
bahamas and are continuing to have a lot
of fun together
but kanye
he isn't really feeling it
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
kanye still isn't too thrilled by pete
and kim's relationship but is doing his
best to stay distracted busy and
fulfilled with his own life of course
the runaway rapper has been spotted out
and about in miami and new york city
with uncut gem star julia fox and on
thursday interview magazine shared these
moody pda-packed pics from the pair's
dinner date turned photo shoot which
kanye apparently arranged without julia
knowing a thing something from my heart
the 31 year old actress shared some
insight into how they met and their big
apple evening with the mag
it was really surreal she explains quote
i met yay in miami on new year's eve and
it was an instant connection
julia said they had so much fun that
they quote decided to keep the energy
going and fly back to new york city to
see slave play the two were snapped on
tuesday after taking in the show then
hit up italian hotspot carbone for
dinner which is where the steamy photo
shoot kicked off julia gush's quote at
the restaurant yay directed an entire
photo shoot for me while people dined
the whole restaurant loved it and
cheered us on while it was happening
then after dinner julia says kanye
brought her to a hotel suite full of
clothes
it was like every girl's dream come true
it felt like a real cinderella moment i
was so surprised like who does things
like this on a second date or any date
julia added that everything has been
quote so organic and adds quote i don't
know where things are headed but if this
is any indication of the future i'm
loving the ride
and an eyewitness doubled down on
julia's sentiment telling et on
wednesday that the two seemed quote
super comfortable with each other adding
that the two were in deep conversation
and didn't seem bothered by the fans and
photographers outside waiting for them
quote it doesn't seem like a new
relationship they seem just happy and at
ease around each other
as for the whole kim and pete thing it's
a different experience for sure
according to et source the snl star
isn't concerned or threatened by the
grammy winner and is just enjoying his
time with kim i love that energy in my
life quote pete is so attracted to her
and thinks she's so cool and smart they
have amazing chemistry and are really
loving their time with each other
[Music]
you